today on the matt wall show we will
expose the people who are openly trying
to normalize and destigmatize pedophilia
it's shocking and you need to hear about
it also dave portnoy goes on the offense
after the media smears him with a me to
hit piece plus the media runs cover for
biden after he uses some very unpc
language during a speech and a male
rapper wears a dress to an award show
and we're still supposed to be shocked
and impressed by this kind of thing i
guess finally in our daily cancellation
we'll deal with the claim that the only
way to save our planet is to stop having
babies all of that and more today on the
matte wall show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so did you know that there are over 10
million job openings but only 7.6
million unemployed job seekers and this
issue is being worsened due to a
mismatch of employers and qualified
talent
so employers are having to go above and
beyond to entice people to want to work
for them
offering all kinds of things providing
discount programs offering legal
services providing identity theft
protection um apparently i'm told also
employers are now offering pet insurance
as well to try to get people into look
if you if it's someone the only way you
can get them to work for you is by
offering pet insurance and that's
probably something you don't want
working for you to begin with
um but if you need to find the right
person for your team zip recruiter is
where you need to go um and you can try
it for free at ziprecruiter.com
walsh right now zip code uses powerful
technology to find and match the right
candidates with your job then it
proactively presents these candidates to
you you can easily review these
recommended candidates and invite your
top choices to apply for your job which
encourages them to uh apply faster this
is all about being proactive
you know and actually going out and
finding the right talent and uh you
could do that with zip recruiter and now
you can try zip recruiter for free at
this exclusive web address zip recruiter
dot com slash walsh that's
ziprecruiter.com walsh ziprecruiter the
smartest way to hire so we must
unfortunately begin the show today
discussing some extremely disturbing
things that you don't want to hear and i
don't want to talk about but then again
the show almost always consists of
things you don't want to hear and i
don't want to talk about so today it
starts with the organization called
the prosthesia foundation if it already
sounds creepy and dystopian well you
don't know the half of it it also has
kind of a pharmaceutical ring to it
which may or may not be intentional i
don't know
prostatia has been around for a few
years it would seem
and it builds itself as a child
protection organization quote unquote
that might sound pretty good
child protection organization that's
that's a good thing
until you go to their website and you
spend
10 or 15 seconds
well you will quickly see that this
child protection organization concerns
itself with such causes as
kink awareness
and sex workers rights
and decriminalizing sexting for children
that's one of the things they want to do
prosthesia insists that there is a sex
positive approach to uh childhood
sexting
the organization is also right now
planning and i'm this is quoting now
from the website planning quote research
into the use of fictional or fantasy
sexual outlets like sex dolls cartoons
and fictional stories
among people who have sexual attractions
to children
now as you may be clued into by now this
is not a child protection organization
quite the opposite but if you need to be
further convinced here's an introductory
video from their website watch this
prestasia foundation is a new child
protection organization dedicated to
promoting laws and policies that are
both effective and constitutional we're
a child protection organization and a
human rights organization we're actually
the first to bring mental health
professionals human rights activists sex
experts and internet platforms together
prestasia takes an evidence-based
approach based on preventing abuse
before it happens i think we're living
in a time when people are
frequently willing to
think that making policy based on belief
is a good idea
i'm not sure that's correct we don't shy
away from controversy for example the
idea that maybe we can change the
behavior of people with a sexual
interest in children or the fact that
the best place people to keep minors out
of sex work or the consensual kink
community are sex workers and kinksters
and so my thing when i encounter minors
in kink is first of all that's great
that you're interested please come back
when you're 18. here are some books to
read we believe that it's possible to
protect children while upholding our
society's most important values such as
tolerance diversity and freedom
we're prestigia foundation
[Music]
so i have that mental filing cabinet
open and i'm going through all of the
potential things i could say
to describe the people in that video
that won't get me banned from youtube
and i'm and i'm
there's nothing so we'll just we'll just
forge ahead yes our society's most
important value tolerance they say now
notice how she says that we have to
protect kids
but we need to also make sure that we're
staying true to society's most important
values now me i would say that society's
greatest priority is protecting kids
but that for them is an afterthought in
comparison to tolerance and what should
we be tolerant of well prestasia makes
it makes it abundantly clear through its
website and videos that we should be
tolerant of we should destigmatize what
it refers to as minor attracted persons
otherwise known as pedophiles
and they are not waging this war for
pedophilia normalization alone first of
all one of the men using the term
very loosely here
one of the men affiliated with this
organization is noah berlatsky and he's
a media figure
who has written for the atlantic the
washington post nbc i mean it's been all
over the place mainstream publications
and he is
works with this organization
that wants to
destigmatize pedophilia
because openly supporting pedophilia
will not preclude you from earning
bylines in major publications quite the
opposite it would seem
and there are others outside the
organization joining in this fight for
pedophilia acceptance including of
course college professors
in fact um just a few days ago uh or
last night as libs of tik tok on twitter
brought to our attention prestigious
youtube channel they haven't been banned
from youtube of course i mean they're
still on youtube
they had an interview with a non-binary
professor from old dominion university
by the name of alan walker
alan walker has just written a book
available on amazon hasn't been banned
on amazon of course
arguing for tolerance of maps minor
attracted persons
here's alan talking about the book and
its arguments
um i use the term minor attracted person
or map in the title and throughout the
book for multiple reasons um first of
all because i think it's important to
use terminology for groups that members
of that group want others to use for
them um and math advocacy groups like
before you act
have advocated for use of the term map
they've advocated for it primarily
because it's less stigmatizing than
other terms like pedophile
a lot of people when they hear the term
pedophile they automatically assume that
it means a sex offender
and that isn't true and it leads to a
lot of misconceptions about attractions
toward minors
i've definitely heard the idea that you
brought up though that the use of the
term minor attracted person suggests
that it's okay to be attracted to
children
but using a term that communicates who
someone is attracted to
doesn't indicate anything about the
morality of that attraction
you know maybe once the fbi is done
investigating soccer moms at school
board meetings they might want to have a
look at alan walker and the prestasia
foundation if it isn't too much trouble
that is
this is all quite horrifying and
nauseating and infuriating but we could
learn something important by listening
to the blood-curdling freak in that
video
now professor them says that we should
call pedophiles
minor attracted persons because it's
polite you know it's what the members of
that group have requested that we do
we should allow groups to define
themselves and we should use whatever
language they assign to us
the last thing we'd ever want to do
professor them says is uh
is rather stigmatize them
now you see how so you see here how the
most the most hideous kinds of evil can
be dragged up from the bowels of hell
and sanitized and normalized
all in the name of politeness
and being respectful to communities
that's step one by the way
once once they start putting the label
community on a group of people
that's step one towards normalization so
now we're talking about the pedophilia
the pedophilia community
uh much like maybe we talk about the
serial killer community or the rapist
community
this is all under the assumption of
course that uh that groups and
individuals should be able to define
themselves and that we should never you
know we should never stigmatize anyone
is what we're being told of course the
people making this argument they don't
really believe it
i'm sure that if a white supremacist
group asked politely that they not be
referred to as white supremacists
nobody on professor them side of the
ball would care about respecting their
group identity
in fact the left will stigmatize people
who are not white supremacists by
calling them white supremacists even
though the people being labeled as such
don't want that label and also don't
warrant it warrant it
so there's no consistency here except in
the sense that the left only applies
this destigmatizing rule to sexual
groups
you know it turns out that they're
they're big fans of stigmatizing things
in general they stigmatize all manner of
groups people ideas beliefs value
systems
they stigmatize a new thing every day
it's almost impossible to keep up
so the destigmatizing campaign is
reserved specially and exclusively
for sexual behavior and orientations and
groups
pedophiles are a
sexual group in a sense and it's always
been only a matter of time before the
campaign begins in earnest to push for
full mainstream acceptance of their
quote-unquote lifestyle choices
i mean the left is marched under the
banner of love is love right for years
and this is where that kind of slogan
leads
by design
now
we'll be told that prestasia and alan
walker and their allies are fringe
and if that were true you know if they
were alone on the field fighting this
battle to normalize pedophilia and
sexualize kids you might not worry about
it so much it would be enough to chalk
them up to a small collection of
disgusting anomalous dirt bags
and if we lived in a sane society they'd
all be going to prison
and that would be it
but the problem is that they're not
alone
just a few days ago we played for you
that news report out of fairfax county
virginia where adolescents and public
schools are being asked explicit
questions about their sexual lives their
sex lives
which isn't even a thing that should
exist
for kids
being asked that by their school for a
survey
yesterday we had the video of a young
boy in a dress and makeup paraded around
by his mother for applause applause what
she does indeed receive
we've talked about the dramatically
increased prevalence of lgbt
identification among kids trans
identification in particular has
skyrocketed in recent years
this this is the result this result has
been engineered precisely by sexualizing
kids from a young age
and as you know from this show the men
who invented the sexual revolution
revolution who invented modern sex ed
and the modern approach to these
subjects men like alfred kinsey wanted
to convince the public to see children
as sexual beings
that was their goal
kinsey even worked closely with
pedophiles in his research he did
experiments to study orgasms in babies
and the kinsey institute still exists
today
and is very well funded
so fringe
no
not at all
and beyond all that of course there's
pop music in hollywood and so on all
together you see that the effort to
sexualize kids and thereby to normalize
the sexualization of kids
is
already mainstream
if prostatia and alan walker are unique
it's just that they have taken all of
this
to its inevitable conclusion
now let's get to our five headlines
[Music]
have you gotten git upside yet the app
that we've been telling you because if
you haven't i don't know what you're
waiting for it really is it's just free
money they're trying to give you free
money and uh some of you are turning it
down you you you insane people my
listeners are making up to 25 cents for
every gallon of gas every time they fill
up just download the free get upside app
in the app store or google play right
now you can use promo code walsh and get
a bonus 25 cents per gallon on your
first phillips that means your first
sell to get 50 cents cash back don't pay
full price of the pump anymore get cash
back using get upside just download the
app for free and use promo code walsh to
get up to 50 cents a gallon cashback on
your first tank then 25 cents a gallon
uh from there on some people who drive a
lot are making you know as much as two
or three hundred dollars a month in cash
back uh the cashback gets added right to
your account it's as easy as that you
cash out any time to your bank account
paypal e-gift card
for amazon and other brands whatever you
want to do it's very easy
there's no catch there's no fine print
anything it's as simple as this just
download the free get upside app and use
promo code walsh and get up to 50 cents
a gallon cashback on your first tank
that's code walsh the get upside app
all right so uh
you know it was it was a nice last night
my my
we had a birthday my son turned five
thank god thank god he turned five
because i tell you what four
four is a battle i mean i've said before
we talk about the terrible twos twos are
the twos are way overrated in terms of
how difficult they are two-year-olds are
really easy
uh four is when the real battle starts
so he turned five and um
we went to uh and this is just a
recommendation i give to to parents
we uh took him you know this is birthday
dinner we went to the rainforest cafe i
don't know if you've ever been to a
rainforest cafe or if you have them
around where you live but uh we love the
rainforest cafe it's it's great
it's horrible i mean it's great because
it's hard it's absolutely terrible the
food is awful the service is awful
um everything about it is bad but
it's loud
and it's obnoxious and it's tacky
and it's you know it's like kind of a
little dirty and so and so you feel
comfortable sitting down there with you
know we got four kids eight and under
and sitting in a there's like no
pressure you don't have to worry about
annoying anybody
you can barely even hear your own kids
across from you at the table which is
another positive another bonus
and um and you just have to accept the
fact that when you know as a parent
and you've got young kids
if if for whatever reason you're crazy
enough to bring them out to a restaurant
if this is not about you you're not
going to have a good time so that this
that that's off the table so forget
about that
um and this is all about minimizing the
stress and just getting through it and
as far as that goes you go to a
rainforest cafe
it's just very loud they've got like
it's it's it's the it's they've got
these animatronic animals all over the
place and these animal noises
and um
it's just it's fantastic all right
it terrible but fantastic
so we'll start with this dave portnoy of
bar stool sports continues to wage war
against business insider justified war a
just war i would say for their me too
hit piece we talked about this last week
on friday
um
right after
the right after the hit piece came out
you know we talked about on this show
and and um
and i
you know i defended dave portnoy because
first of all he was accused
well i mean he wasn't accused of rape or
sexual assault
not in those words at all he was not
accused of that this is a me too
kind of
what they did with the articles they
wanted to give the impression
that he was a rapist
and they wanted to give the impression
that he'd been accused of rape by
multiple women but he hasn't been
and even in the article
which was of course behind a
paywall um which means that many people
didn't read it all they saw were the
head was the headline and the headline
said something about dave portnoy had
violent and disturbing sex
and i said to you last week that's a big
red flag i mean violent and disturbing
sex that sounds bad but if
if if he was being accused of rape they
would put that in the headline they
wouldn't describe it some other way they
would say dave portnoy allegedly uh you
know
commits rape or alleged rape they would
put that in the headline the fact that
they didn't put it in the headline they
tried to find other words that sort of
suggest it but don't say it
big red flag
then if you actually read the article
you find that yeah um they they spent
eight months
digging through
dave portnoy's life because they decided
ahead of time they want to take him down
and they figure this is a single guy and
he's successful and he's very open about
the fact that he has a lot of casual sex
so he's got he has a lot of sex partners
out there
and they said we're gonna we're gonna
talk to all of these women until we find
a few that will accuse him
of sexual assault they couldn't find any
that would accuse him of sexual assault
so they kind of went i guess they went
to their plan b their backups
and they found women that um had sexual
experiences with dave portnoy don't like
him anymore
and don't feel great about the
experience but they but they don't say
that it was right they say it was
so
consensual
spent eight uh eight uh months doing
that and um and then that's what they
found they found i guess two really they
found two women
who felt
icky about their dalliance with portnoy
and they felt that he was you know a
creep or whatever
um pornoy has been on the offensive ever
since then he had a press conference
yesterday which is really more of a live
stream where he went through the
allegations he dug up text messages that
he's had with these accusers
um
and he showed how they were in in one
case one of the women accusing him and
again i got to keep putting quotes
around accusing because it's not even
clear what exactly are they accusing him
of that's never made clear
so um one of the quote-unquote accusers
he showed how
after the facts
she was texting with him
all happy and flirtatious
and then later claimed that she was
traumatized by the experience
um and uh the other accuser
the first one mentioned in the uh and
this is where the the headline comes
from a violent and disturbing
this is the woman who
contacted dave portney and told him she
had a rape fantasy
and then they set up that she was going
to come to his
mansion and they were going to have sex
and so she came for that reason
um
portnoy in his video shows how she after
this hit piece came out
she has been in public i guess on i
think this is on her tic-tock account
she has been saying publicly
that she was not raped that this was
consensual let's uh let's watch some of
that here
she met again a random cause she
messaged him said she want to explore
her rape fantasy that's a fact she came
over they did we did not exploit rape
fantasy we did not um she is of age she
never said no sounds consensual to me uh
the creator her
the article never said the sex wasn't
consensual i am getting crucified and
dragged through the coals
on a girl who is openly in the public
being i never said it wasn't uh
conceptual and it wasn't rape again they
keep stopping short because they know
that's an investigation and if something
happened pleaser but whatever she's
saying that she doesn't even know i'm
looking at this by the way so it's not
like she's being provoked this is she's
doing on her own answering it um
we dig a little more like where'd this
animosity come from exhibit 14.
july 20th so that is when she left dave
porton equals little
again
doesn't sound like
i told you we didn't get along
that's what you write once when you
don't get along with somebody you do not
write that i don't think i don't know
when you've been assaulted like little
[ __ ] is like he's
um
exhibit 15 please
this is all dug up after the fact that
net worth thanks to this hit piece is
probably like half that [ __ ] now uh
below it
that so that's my net worth thanks for
the update that's her
i don't know how you can delete that
venmo at me
how much money i'm worth
venmo okay
interesting
okay so this is this is
really that
this was like the headline accusation
that they made the business insider was
from apparently from this woman
dave portnoy says and she has now said
publicly that well this
this this was this was not
non-consensual which means it was
consensual because it's either
consensual or not right
um
i mean does anyone want is anyone on the
left want to say that it's that you know
you could have
uh that there's some in between between
consensual and non-consensual no it's
consensual or it's or it's
non-consensual this was consensual so
she said that publicly
and then he brings up how again after
their
uh after they had sex she was tweeting
at him she put her venmo up
on his twitter account like this is just
full-on hit piece that's all this is
trying to destroy somebody
and i think there are two points to make
about this which
both of them already sort of sort of
made but i'm going to reiterate
um
the first one is
okay this
a lot of this is this is hookup culture
this is
the
what what these women are experiencing
to the extent that they're being honest
at all about their feelings
and he goes on to talk about how that
woman the first one
you know the reason why it didn't work
out is because they're in very different
political sides of the of the aisle and
uh so she's far far left-wing and so for
her this she might be motivated entirely
just by politics but to the extent that
they're being honest about their
feelings
what what happened
was they went for a consensual hookup
and it was consensual
as everyone agrees that's the crazy
thing about this
that you've got you know you usually
talk about what he said she said well in
this case you've got a sexual experience
there's only two people involved only
two people were there
both of them are saying it was
consensual
and yet you've got the media and people
in the in the peanut gallery saying it
wasn't who weren't there and don't know
anything about it
um so what really happened is they went
they had a consensual experience
and um
and they didn't feel good about it the
next day
they had they had regret they felt used
she talked about in the article she felt
like she was used like a sex doll
well yeah
i mean she was it but but that's also
what she was doing to him
that's what hook of culture is you're
using each other like
sex dolls you are you are using in
hookup culture you are using another
human being
like a glorified masturbatory aid okay
that's what hook up culture is
it is sex with another human being
reduced down basically to the level of
masturbation where where you are
where the other person almost doesn't
they don't exist as a human being
you're not worried about who they are
you might not even hardly know their
name you don't know anything about them
you don't certainly don't love them you
have no commitment to them
so you're not engaging with them as a as
a human you're not you're not worried
about their humanity and their deepest
uh fears and worries and values and all
that
you're just trying to get something out
of them you're trying to get this sexual
experience out of them
um
and in a way it's like they might as
well just be a sex robot that's how
you're treating each other
that's what hook-up culture is
and yet you wake up the next morning and
you're feeling used well you were
but you weren't raped
and as i as i always say because we've
we have gotten rid of all of the
language to describe sexual morality
we've chipped it all away
and all we have now is consent that's
the one
sexual boundary that we have still left
in place
and so when someone wakes up the next
day
feeling bad about what happened
the
only language that they have
the only boundary they recognize is
consent and so they figure well i guess
consent was violated
because they think that as long as sex
is consensual then it's supposed to be
good
and i'm supposed to feel great about it
and if i don't feel great about it then
then i guess it wasn't consensual
um
and
the second thing of course is poor noise
showing how to respond to cancer culture
which is which is really important
it's a really important lesson
being falsely accused staying on the
offense
means going after business insider
he's he is addressing this directly he's
not like apologizing for anything
because he didn't do anything he didn't
do any he didn't do anything wrong
um
except to engage in in in hook up
culture which i would say is morally
wrong but that's that that is
that that was equally wrong on both ends
and that's also not why he's being
attacked by business insider unless
business insider wants to put out a you
know
wants to wage some campaign against
hookup culture in general but you better
you better you better throw a bunch of
other people into that pot with dave
porter he's certainly not the only one
so he's not apologizing he's defending
himself
you know he's he's going after business
insider he's putting these text messages
out there
and that's exactly what you need to do
and another
benefit i think is that he's kind of
indirectly and unintentionally putting
pressure
on the next guy
who is me tood in a dishonest way like
this
because the next guy now now really if
this happens to you
and you do what so many other men have
done and just clam up and start
apologizing
while not exactly admitting guilt but
you clam up you don't say anything
people are gonna say wait why you know
dave portnoy came out and he was
aggressive about it why aren't you what
are you doing are you guilty
and hopefully that will push people to
say no do the exact same thing get out
in front of it defend defend yourself
look at what happened to in aziz ansari
i mean there's so many examples aziz i'm
sorry is one example
a very similar sort of thing where he
was he there was a me too hit piece on
him he wasn't really accused of sexual
assault it was it was never clear
exactly what they're even accusing him
of
um except that they were trying to sort
of gin up the impression that he
committed sexual assault without saying
it which is exactly what they're doing
to
dave portnoy and ansari's response was
kind of you know he didn't say much and
then he sort of apologized and then he
kind of went away and uh
and now he's and and so this label has
just stuck on him
rather than coming out aggressively
head-on and
meeting this
as you should as an innocent person
okay um so we have to play this just for
fun here is joe biden
using well
maybe i'll just play the clip and then
uh and then you know we'll talk about
how to interpret this go ahead
you know i've adopted the
attitude of the great
negro at the time pitcher in the negro
leagues went on to become
a great pitcher in the pros into the
major league baseball after jackie
robinson
his name was satchel page
yeah the the great negro at the time
that's what he said
now the media has been running
cover for biden on this of course and
they've done
you know already we get the fact checks
i'm sure snopes is already on the case
and they've done the fact checks and uh
i i bet this is something where already
if you were to put something on facebook
saying that
uh joe biden used the word negro
you know
facebook would fact check it probably so
they're they're
running the fact check the running cover
for joe biden
on this
but he did you know and we he did say it
and we know of course
no doubt whatsoever that if if if donald
trump
had said exactly that those words
verbatim
this would be headline news everywhere
and they would they'd be talking about
for the next 10 years they'd never shut
up about it
um and it would be there would be
probably marches in the streets and it
would be a crisis that the president's
arrest they would probably impeach him i
think i think he would have gotten
impeached a third time if he had uh if
he had
said something like that
but in reality of course it is yeah i'll
admit it is a little
even though
we know they would do this to
trump the attack on biden here from the
right it's a little cheap i mean i think
i i do think he meant to say
great negro league pitcher originally
and then he kind of because he's joe
biden he stumbled over his words
uh so that's that's three and also
it's all arbitrary anyway
like why exactly is negro uh politically
incorrect but you could still say negro
league so that that exists i mean that's
that's the name of something so you
can't but you can't you can't so that's
okay
but in any other context you can't use
that word
it's just like person of color versus uh
colored people
i love that one that's the most
arbitrary switch
in pc language it's actually pretty
funny
you say colored people say whoa so
that's that's racist what am i supposed
to say people of color
what
what possible difference is there
between those two things
you're just flipping the words around
and if you ask somebody that what
they'll tell you is that well well uh
you know people of color is is
is better because it puts the humanity
first it puts humanity before race and
if you say colored person then you're
putting the race before humanity but
that's why you want and that's why and
that's why that's why it's better
that's why one is horribly racist and
the other is is the most pc thing to say
well then but what about black person
i can say that can't i
well and that's put it and that's
putting race first
so it doesn't make any sense it's
entirely arbitrary and the real reason
though
anytime you do this with the left when
it comes to pc language or anything else
and you're trying to understand well why
is that the rule though like explain to
me because you can't tell me it's
putting humanity first because as i've
already proven that can't be it
so really why why why can you say one
not the other
honest question i think it's a it's a
perfectly valid question
the real answer is
from the left most of the time the real
answer is
the same answer i give to my kids
um when i'm annoyed with their questions
the classic parent answers because i
said so
and that's actually the answer from the
left on this
or on so many other things but
especially when it comes to the words
you're allowed to use versus the words
you're not allowed to use
and they might try to come up with some
kind of justification or rationale for
their arbitrary declarations but when it
comes down to it the real answer is
because i said so because the left said
so that's it we said it and that's why
you have to do it
all right um
more from the media here the media
basically realizes i think at this point
that rittenhouse is innocent um they're
not gonna come out and say that directly
but they realize it and they realize
that uh he should be acquitted and you
know it's pretty good likelihood that he
will be
so now they're looking for a different
narrative
um
a way that their priors on this case can
still be confirmed even if everything
they said about written house is wrong
and chris hayes in his monologue the
other night he thinks he's uh stumbled
on on what the what the narrative should
be
that's the message that was being pushed
to a 17 year old kyle ridden house a
child
he heard warnings about the boogeyman of
black lives matter and antifa
and he took this illegally acquired
assault weapon
which he emits not for hunting or for
home defense
and he throws himself at the fray in
kenosha
and he kills two people
the boy
who killed people the boy who killed
people
is then celebrated
by the same pro-gun law and order
culture that produced him as a hero and
a martyr
and he's bailed out with the help of
right-wing activists and he poses for a
photo grinning in the t-shirt of a long
gun themed coffee company
that then courted controversy from the
right when it distanced itself from this
person this boy who'd killed two people
accused of homicide
there's a legal question before the jury
right now of kyle rittenhouse's guilt or
innocence it's being determined will be
determined
from what i've seen i think it's pretty
likely he'll be acquitted honestly
there's also the broader question of
what kind of society we want to live in
ask yourself that
if you're watching this and you're a gun
owner or or or someone who considers
yourself uh a defender of the second
amendment abstractly right ask yourself
do we want a society in which political
conflict is settled on the streets
between people with guns
right so
predictable i mean they're nothing
nothing if not predictable but
predictably
uh this becomes a case of a gun culture
gone wrong and this is this is what this
is really about and
uh he he says in that monologue he
acknowledges that that's pretty good
chance he's gonna be acquitted
and he doesn't say because he's because
he's innocent but that's
yeah he he realizes that they all do
there's no getting around it
and so now we're going to have a
conversation about gun culture
and why why was this boy there in the
first place
now by the way now he gets to be a boy
again did you notice that not now he's a
kid
so for a while he was like a grown man
when they thought they could they could
hang a murder charge on him he was a
grown man and that's what that's what it
is but now that they want to make this
about guns specifically now that they've
moved now that they realize that they're
not going to get the murder thing and
now they want to make it about guns now
it's convenient for him to be a boy a
child again because why is this child
have a gun
so you notice how that switch has
happened
um and they they want to make it an ex
a discussion about gun culture
when of course it isn't
but if you want to talk about
culture as it relates to the kyle
rittenhouse case
well we could do that
um
like the culture in america and in our
cities now
that allows for rampant lawlessness and
rioting
i mean that is what actually led to
everything that happened that night
as i said from the beginning you know
you want to put anybody
on trial
for for what happened in kenosha
aside from all the rioters who should be
in jail almost none of them are almost
none of them were convicted or even
charged with anything
but how about the mayor
of the city and the governor of the
state who allowed this this this to
happen
that's what they
we keep hearing how kyle written house
wasn't supposed to be there he shouldn't
have been there what he was what was he
doing there
and uh we're just supposed to accept
that all of the rioters
rampaging through the streets
burning down buildings
okay so they're allowed to be there
why was kyle rittenhouse there why was
he actually there
because kyle rittenhouse had
determined
that um
law enforcement was not going to do its
job or was not going to be allowed to do
its job
you know law in in order had been in
kenosha like in many cities in in the
summer of 2020 lawed order had been
abandoned had been officially abandoned
but basically canceled it was the purge
now we're not going to have law order
and we're just going to let these these
animals run through the street and do
whatever they want
and there were some people who
felt called they felt like they had a
responsibility to step into that void
now you could say that they shouldn't
have done that that they that you know
that it was a stupid thing to do
as i said i would call that more
courageous
doing what you think is the right thing
doing the right thing
even when you know you're putting
yourself in harm's way i mean we used to
call that courageous they used to be
considered brave to do that
but no matter how you describe it
the problem is that that void existed in
the first place
the people who created that void they're
the ones that we should be blaming
um here's something i want to just
mention briefly uh from the new york
post is a 16 month old alabama boy who
weighed less than a pound when he was
born at 21 weeks and one day and set a
world record being named the most
premature infant to survive according to
guinness world records
curtis means and his twin uh siesta had
a less than one percent chance to
survive after they were born
to michelle butler at uab hospital in
birmingham in july of 2020 a full-term
pregnancy is usually 40 weeks making the
siblings about 19 weeks premature
sadly the the twin sister died the
following day but her brother who
weighed a mere 14.8 ounces at birth
uh has survived and he set a new world
record so this was a child
born at 21 weeks and survived
now
we we shouldn't need to connect the dots
here and spell this all out but
you know if a child can survive at 21
weeks
but
maybe that should tell you something
about the people who want you know they
tell us well we could have an abortion
at 21 weeks it's just it's just a blob
of cells a clump of cells
yeah this child was delivered at 21
weeks is he still a blob just a blob of
cells
or did that magically change upon
delivery how does that work exactly
and the thing is as medical science
progresses and progresses
um
the the idea of
viability you know that the threshold is
going to go down and down to now it's
going to be lowered
so anyone who tries to you know draw
lines by
in terms of viability to support
abortion well that you know medical
science is making that very very
difficult and you also see how medical
science
has
only vindicated every day more and more
the pro-life position
every medical advancement
in this realm
has only shown more and more has only
has only continually affirmed the
humanity of the unborn
all right kid cudi got up to some antics
at the cfda fashion awards this week now
most likely the majority of that last
sentence means nothing to you
that's okay you don't need to know much
about it only that kid cudi is some kind
of rapper i guess in the cfda fashion
awards are fashion awards
and mr kidd decided to attend this
prestigious event
i assume it's prestigious i don't know
wearing a dress
a wedding dress specifically complete
with a veil and everything and his date
was a man and a tuxedo
and you can see the pictures
there and this of course being
celebrated by by the media i think it
was vogue so this is a bold fashion
choice
and you see this kind of thing and it's
just
i mean you look at this guy
it's like it's just set it's kind of sad
and awkward and weird
because there's nothing at all even
unusual about this anymore
about a guy dressing up like a girl
nothing and certainly nothing
revolutionary about it
like they always want to pretend each
time
this happens a million times and every
single time it's a revolutionary act
it's certainly not revolutionary it's
not even unusual
every single award show now there's like
50 men in dresses all competing for
attention on the uh on the red carpet
and because it doesn't have any of that
doesn't have any of the the novelty
it just becomes even more obvious how
kind of sad and awkward it is it's just
like this sad awkward guy
and it looks like a sad awkward guy in
his sister's clothes
begging for attention which of course is
all he is
very revolutionary there good stuff okay
now let's get to our comment section
[Music]
says matt you're missing the
significance of the dislike button
they're trying to stop people from
having a voice and they want to make you
feel like you're alone
go to trending click on a cnn video and
the dislike ratio is major people think
i can't stand cnn everyone agrees with
me same reason why netflix removed the
star rating system um amy schumer's
special was one starred
yeah that of course is
i understand in reality and i was
talking yesterday about how they're
getting rid of the dislike button
for youtube creators
and i i really appreciate youtube as as
a youtube creator myself i appreciate
youtube looking out for my feelings but
i realize i'm not i'm not that stupid i
realize they don't care about my
feelings it's not me that they're
looking out for
uh it's they're trying to save yeah cnn
and all these left-wing accounts
who get a lot of dislikes
because people don't like the co the
content
and um
and it's not even so much that they want
to protect
the feelings of the left-wing content
creators i mean that's part of it
but as you point out
you know they don't want other they
don't want you to know as a viewer
that you are not alone in disliking this
content they don't want you to know how
many of you are out there and so that's
why i i do understand that
um
and then a bunch of kayla says sorry
buddy 109 dislikes on this video still
visible and a lot of comments like that
apparently so you could still at least
on my videos you look down there right
now you can still see i guess the
dislike button
and that that will be will be funny this
is how it all turns out that they they
only disable the dislike button for
certain accounts but for me they'll keep
it on there
109 people disliked my show yesterday
you bastards
um
let's see bryce says the ivf story from
today is a pro-choice contradiction
isn't it if the baby simply became a
human upon birth
then whoever carried it would have to be
the mother
a statement that says a baby can belong
to someone other than the woman carrying
it implies that the baby is a distinct
entity prior to its birth
very good point i wish i had
drawn that connection made that point
very well done
um
i should have just pretended i didn't
read that comment and made the point on
my own and claimed it for my own sean
says if kyle was fake crying give him an
oscar
uh yeah that's that's the other the the
claim that people don't understand i
think how the fact that
the fact that most people are very bad
actors like acting is is actually a rare
skill
um
and so when you see kyle rittenhouse on
the stand and you see him having a panic
attack and crying
well you you know it's genuine
because of what he's going through and
how any human would react that way
um but also that's not something you
can't fake that unless you're a trained
thespian you you can't fake that that is
raw human emotion
uh no no way around it
um
eric says you're wrong the prosecution
doesn't need to prove kyle shot three
people that was stipulated by the
defense
the burden of proof is on the defense to
prove an exception to the murder
statutes which is self-defense
please do some research before creating
your videos thanks
the burden of proof is on the defense uh
no eric that's
you you're
you're extremely confused about the
basic facts of our legal system
as i always stipulate i'm not a lawyer i
don't claim to be a legal expert
but i do know this at least the
presumption of innocence
is like the foundation of our legal
system
it's the most fundamental thing
uh this is perhaps the most fundamental
principle of our legal system is that
you have the presumption of innocence as
an accused person so no the burden of
proof is not on the defense at all it
never is at least it's not supposed to
be that's not how it's supposed to work
yeah we know that kyle rittenhouse shot
three people guess what shooting people
is not against the law
there's no law anywhere that says
you don't shoot people
i'm killing people also isn't against
the law
it depends on the reason and the
motivation and the circumstance
you know self-defense is legal
everywhere
so the the presumption of the if there's
a presumption of an innocence then the
presumption has to be that it was
self-defense
it's up to the prosecutor to prove
otherwise
and they didn't
so a little uh little legal legal 101
for you today
quick uh quick trip into law school glad
i could do that for you you know last
week the daily wire filed a lawsuit
against the federal government for the
unconstitutional mandates that the
administration is forcing on large
employers and their employees
this isn't something we enjoy doing no
one likes being involved in a lawsuit
but we're happy to do it to see that's
um and be able to apply pressure and
create change it's already working the
fifth circuit court of appeals issued a
temporary stay preventing biden's
mandate from going into effect citing
graves statutory and constitutional
issues
that's a good first step step but this
is not over yet not by a long shot
really the fight is just beginning and
we're not just fighting for the daily
wire employees we're fighting for
medical freedom for all people this is
an urgent matter and your medical
freedom depends on it if you want to
support the fight to make your personal
medical decisions without government
interference sign our petition against
biden's authoritarian mandate today
hundreds of thousands of americans have
already signed the petition in just a
few days but we need many more people to
stand with us to reach our goal so
please head to dailywire.com
do not comply to sign
the petition today also daily wires own
andrew clavin is a brilliant suspense
novelist and his newest book when
christmas comes is available everywhere
you buy books described as wonderful
gripping and a pure delight by the great
dean coons himself the book centers
around the story of a sleuthing english
teacher who will need a christmas
miracle to prove a condemned man
innocent it's a seasonal tale of
tradition family and of course murder
its chilling twists our best experience
curled up beside a burning yule log go
pick up a copy for yourself
or your thrill-seeking loved ones at
amazon or anywhere you buy books today
just in time for christmas now let's get
to our daily cancellation
[Music]
today we cancel uh population matters
which is a charity quote unquote that
campaigns for as it puts it a
sustainable human population which is
another way of saying that they want
fewer people on earth right
traditionally you know charities have
focused on helping humans flourish
but these days especially in
self-loathing predominantly white
western countries we have charities with
the exact opposite attention population
matters just a few weeks after giving an
award to harry and megan for pledging to
limit their family size um they had a
big presence at the un's climate
conference where they unveiled a giant
inflatable baby to raise awareness of
the fact that there are too many babies
in the world or at least in the west
you'll notice again again that that all
of these organizations
worried about overpopulation they always
focus on mostly white countries
and that's not a coincidence either
let's uh let's hear what they have to
say
so population matters is here in glasgow
at cop26 and you can see we've got a big
baby who's just been inflated and we're
drawing attention to the fact that in a
rich developed country like the uk like
scotland like england choosing to have a
smaller family is the best thing you can
do to take the heat off the planet and
also of course we have choice here
whereas hundreds of millions of women
across the world don't have that choice
don't have that right and we want to
draw attention to that because if we can
meet
that unmet
choice and right for safe modern family
planning for the number of kids you have
when whether you have kids that is also
not just brilliant for people and for
their well-being but it's also great for
the well-being of the planet it will
save more carbon dioxide than all
onshore and offshore wind power combined
it's the number two solution to climate
change and yet we've hardly heard
population talked about
at cop26
other than from population matters
right so let's uh let's go through a few
points here both in response to
population matters and to the
overpopulation myth generally
first of all overpopulation is indeed a
myth and this all hinges on the
obviously absurd notion that the earth
has some sort of max capacity for human
life
and we've almost reached it or already
exceeded it
the overpopulation myth was invented out
of thin air a few decades ago around the
time that environmentalists and
eugenicists were telling us about the
imminent ice age which apparently came
and went and destroyed mankind without
anybody noticing
in reality the earth really has no
carrying capacity or if it does we'll
never get close to it
as it stands we have enough room on
earth
to fit the entire population of the
world into texas
and enough resources to feed them all
three times over
it's not a coincidence that articles and
news stories about overpopulation they
always come accompanied by images of
people in manhattan or tokyo all crammed
together in a train or on a sidewalk
for some reason they never show you the
vast swathes of empty land where nobody
currently lives they never show you like
north dakota or rural china
it's our choice to mostly not live in
north dakota perhaps our cities our
cities might have a population limit and
even that limit is quite flexible but
the earth is enormous and ancient
and resilient and it can handle it all
of us
this goes for the climate too by the way
the earth has endured massive swings in
temperatures highs and lows ice ages
warm periods the earth has been hit by
asteroids the size of cities there have
been super volcano eruptions cataclysm
after cataclysm the idea that it could
be crippled brought to its knees because
we're having too many babies
is ridiculous
also let's keep in mind always that
climate change was supposed to have
already brought about the extinction of
the human race several times by now
it hasn't probably because climate
change isn't that big of a deal
which isn't to say that the climate
change doesn't exist of course of course
it exists of course the climate is
changing
it always changes
the earth has warmed very slightly over
the past century and a half uh it's it's
now mostly stopped warming and there's
no real evidence that human beings
contributed to it in any significant way
it's probably for this reason that there
really is no there isn't any scientific
consensus on climate change and never
was
second thing human beings are not
commodities
even if it could be proven that an
excess of children may lead to this or
that problematic outcome it still would
not be morally justified to treat
children as if they can be in excess
either we believe that human life is
sacred and each life holds infinite
value or we don't and if we don't
then i'm not sure why we're having this
conversation or any conversation life is
meaningless
therefore the polar bears and the trees
and all the fish in the sea are also
meaningless
therefore the earth is meaningless
therefore we may as well kill ourselves
and escape this painful nothingness of
existence
certainly if human life has no intrinsic
value
then we shouldn't bother ourselves by
worrying about you know silly things
like murder and rape and so forth
who cares what one worthless accidental
clump of matter does to another it's all
the same in the end
it's only possible and sensible to
continue this conversation if we agree
that life has value and that its value
is inherent
so if we're moving forward with that
understanding we must agree that each
life is worth the trouble that it may
supposedly potentially cause
life is not a thing that can be measured
counted rationed
even by an activist standing in front of
a giant inflatable baby
third thing speaking of which why hasn't
that dude
removed himself from the equation
it's fascinating to note that those who
worry about overpopulation
they never seem to put themselves in the
over category right
as i think it was gk chesterton observed
that a hundred years ago
but if a person truly believed that the
surplus of humanity on earth has become
a moral crisis
is that person not morally obliged to
minimize that surplus in the only way he
really can
yet the overpopulation crusaders
continue to breathe
live their lives annihilating another
polar bear family as we speak refusing
to lead by example it's unconscionable
now let me stipulate that that i am not
sincerely advocating suicide i'm only
demonstrating the insincerity of their
position
four i hate to beat a dead horse or or
bear i suppose but why are we still
trying to save the pandas
to go back to that for a second because
i can't make sense of this
on the one hand environmentalists tell
us that carbon emissions are destroying
the planet and we have to have fewer
children to address the epidemic but on
the other hand
they say that we must do everything we
can to stave off the extinction of
pandas and koalas and other effectively
useless species who seem to want very
badly to die off
we're basically forcing pandas to have
sex we're so desperate to keep them
around why i mean they emit carbon too
don't they
why are humans the ones who need to
embrace extinction
if there are too many
biological creatures on earth and if we
need to curb the expansion of this
horrid disease called life
why wouldn't we start with the creatures
who are near extinction anyway
and who have less value than human
beings
all i'm saying is that don't tell me to
have fewer kids while you're out there
artificially inseminating koala bears
for god's sake
fifth point speaking of sustainability
what's the long-term plan here
as our birth rate slows and western
countries dip below replacement level
the population is thrown out of balance
you end up with a population that grows
older and older on average with fewer
and fewer younger people and that's the
whole idea of course but then but then
who takes care of all these older people
see throughout human history the plan
has always been for people to have kids
more than one kid lots of kids
preferably
and as they grow older
they have a whole expanding
family tree to lean on for support
but our trees in the west are decaying
and becoming top heavy and once they
collapse what then
who's going to care for all of these
childless millennials as they grow old
well the government of course that's the
plan anyway
breeding dependence on government is the
point in the end
of really all of this
yet the government can't take the place
of family much as it may claim otherwise
and it certainly can't save you from
dying alone unmourned and unloved if you
take the advice to forego having
children
for the sake of the climate
or the planet
but i suppose you'll have the climate
there to keep you company at the end at
least
and that's why uh we have to say that
population matters and really the entire
overpopulation myth which is again once
again a myth is today canceled
and that'll do it for us today and the
week have a great weekend talk to you
next week godspeed
[Music]
the matt walsh show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producer is mathis
glover
our technical director is austin stevens
production manager pablo vadosky the
show is edited by ali hinkle
our audio is mixed by mike coromina
hair makeup is done by cherokee heart
and our production coordinator is
mckenna waters the matt wall show is a
daily wire production copyright daily
wire 20 21.
hey everybody this is andrew clavin host
of the andrew clavin show you know some
people are depressed because the
republic is collapsing the end of days
is approaching and the moons turn to
blood but on the andrew clavin show
that's where the fun just gets started
so come on over to the andrew clavin
show and laugh your way through the fall
of the republic with me andrew clavin